hi I'm Candace Cameron Bure and I'm
Jodie Sweetin
and I'm Andrea barber and we're about to
take the BuzzFeed BFF test all right
what are all of our birthdays
I'm your 3rd July be January 17 you are
January 19th and you're in April 6 you
say will be both screwed up there we go
what are our astrological signs
Candace is an Aries Aries and Jodi is uh
Jodi straddles wait the signs
Capaldi no Capricorn and Tyson's
aquarius capita queries for right on I'm
like the day of I'm run on the cusp yeah
you're Aries is Rhea what's July Leo
nope no that's later
Gemini Gemini's June I'm a crab your
place answer I'm no cancer got it what
are our middle names hello Leanne
sweetly yeah that's it yep Helene and
Andrea Johnny you don't know you know a
letter starts with an L Lynn Lee look
Lana look Lola Labrador so close what
are our parents names be Barb's and
Donna Sheri their real names Jerry
that's right he knows his parents
Candace's parents are Barbara and Robert
my parents are Janice and Sam okay what
are the names of our siblings
Candace has a lot perk Bridget Melissa
Melissa mm-hmm Jodi like many and you
guys know
my brother's games Carol Darren Warren
sorry Darren and Justin Justin yes I
called them by other names around you
guys but yes Justin the names of our
current pets if we have any Boris and
Holly
we don't have any right yep no I have a
part I have a part-time pet that is my
friend's dog but he comes and hangs out
with us when the kids are here because
he is very attached so I have a he puts
a surprising amount for only being at my
house a partial amount of the time okay
what nineties trend would you a hundred
percent bring back Candace would bring
back leg warmers I feel like bait
warmers totally would also feel like
crop sweatshirts Jodi would would bring
back the plaid flannel yeah you know
yeah I feel like Andrea with the
stitching the Ramos did she we have I
used to have those I wore those every
day and like 70s what about the Steve
madding platforms black flip-flops that
everyone had please don't point please
no flip-flops yes okay what do we think
each other's favorite full house episode
or story line is I'm gonna get Joe DS is
when she drove the car through the
kitchen
mmm that was pretty awesome although
that one and the full house one the one
where Stephanie I think she gets chicken
pox and tries to like get out of the
house or whatever in the trench coat and
the little hat that was that one is for
whatever reason and I'm like hanging on
the door and the whole thing like that
was just a really cute little tiny bear
in your trench coat and then I had to
make the little boys I feel like I know
it isn't Andrea's favorite episode of
full house most all of them
99% brother one
we were at the college party and you had
to pretend to act drunk oh yeah it's so
cute because you were like um I've never
been drunk is the did you it was so cute
my favorite is when DJ forgets Kimmy
16th birthday
that's right Brown cake in the toilet
paper streamers Candace's favorite her
favorite full house episode I was gonna
say prom but I feel like you hate that
tape that episode
yeah meet that one okay um that's it I
don't even remember full house
storylines enough like all I can think
of her fuller house storylines and
whenever there was a stunt that was
candid when Candice was happiest oh yeah
she was doing the wrestling or you know
any of that God dodge ball dodge ball
yet all of that is when she's happiest
what's the favorite guest star we've
ever worked with Oh New Kids on Blaha
yeah that yours too I feel like that's
my bouquet for those of you guys and us
yeah yeah for Joe mine was the donkey
donkey know your Little Richard when he
put Richard when I got back handed by
Little Richard Oh may he rest in peace
Little Richard we left him what does the
TV show we binge watched out lame and
this is an outlander yeah maybe maybe
for both of you both of you know Jonah
shut up she's called nobody's caught up
I feel like Andrea is searching for a
show though right now you just finished
Oh Melissa Melissa tea yes right oh you
just that's right Joey just um no one's
gonna guess what I'm pinching oh my gosh
what I'd be sun-like dark his gory yeah
well no actually what I've been binge
watching the two days is a political
commentary
dirty money now uh Patriot Act's
what are our favorite movies I honestly
have no idea what your guys's all-time
favorite I quote mine all the time but I
don't think you guys have ever seen it I
I haven't seen most of what you love
Jodie me okay Jodie you're out of your
element
like Candace this is like dirty dancing
your clothes
we sang one of the songs from this movie
on fuller house Oh Oh greedy yep I feel
like hers is a live recorded concert of
New Kids on the Block that answer will
work for the remainder of this test if
you just put some sort of new kids on
the block
what's your favorite movie I don't think
that means what you think it means
oh but Princess Bride yes yes the other
highly quotable movie
our biggest childhood celebrity crush
okay Andrea's Joey McIntyre
so not just child Jodie's is right yeah
Ryan Gosling yes although I've sort of
moved on from him these days
but childhood for sure Charlotte Fisher
in Candace George Michael oh yeah I can
go with George Michael for sure yeah
okay you got a picture with him and with
John John grabbed me and then Oh Michael
had no shirt on and just like a little
cropped bolero jacket that was and I
remember putting my arm around his what
are our coffee orders Candice's is
America triple americano with steamed no
almond milk oh man oh yeah Jodi's is
black coffee black yeah and andrea's my
change is a lot I was gonna say it's
like I see you drinking iced coffee yeah
what is our favorite swear word all of
them
you don't swear Candace so yeah candy
doesn't Kansas it's where yours is oh
mylanta like literally that is your
favorite curse word mine's all mice all
of them I mean it you know depends on
the situation what's called for you know
how creative I need to be Andrew chooses
hers why
well it depends on if I'm drinking the a
for my a for mentioned margarita right
then the f-bomb comes out okay what is
our favorite go-to karaoke song oh baby
for Candace yes yeah or or summer lovin
or someone like yes but if I'm solo
baby's got that yes Candace was singing
baby got back on karaoke in Lucky Strike
on for a wrap party and didn't none of
us realize that everything that was
being saying inside could be her song
inside could be heard out on the street
so as I'm leaving Candace is getting it
to baby got back and I walk out and just
recorded it and send it to her like hey
everyone out here can hear you it was
pretty awesome
Andrea's karaoke song anything by new
kids on the block yeah yeah okay wait
what was the song that Jody karaoke to
in Japan
Jefferson Airplane West Jefferson
Airplane I don't know if that's your
go-to but it was yeah it is
I do yeah somebody to love you shucks 12
out of 16 on the list you know
absolutely everything there is to know
about your best friend yay who knows
what if we would have failed it
[Music]
[Music]
you